im kampf gegen das virus die bundeswehr
holt deutsche aus china zurück in bayern
hat sich erstmals ein kind angesteckt
jetzt schlägt exit nach 47 jahren
verlässt großbritannien heute nacht die
europäische union und aus in australien
alexander zwirner verpasst bei den
australian open den einzug ins finale
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers freitagabend hier ist
ihr überblick über diese nachrichten tag
herzlich willkommen dazu polizei ist bei
uns für den sport hallo guten ab wir
beginnen mit der aktuellen situation
beim corona virus da gibt es auch heute
wieder viele neue fälle vor allem in
china und auch einen neuen in bayern
erstmals ist dort ein kind betroffen es
hat sich bei seinem vater angesteckt der
zu den ersten infizierten in deutschland
gehörte die gesamte familie ist jetzt
isoliert und auch das ist neu
gesundheitsminister jens spahn hat am
abend verfügt ärzte kliniken und labore
müssen ab sofort auch begründete
verdachtsfälle melden
bisher galt das nur für bestätigte
infektionen volker dutschek und was wir
bisher wissen über ein virus und seine
ansteckungswege die sanitäter kamen als
es schon dunkel war packten koffer ein
und brachten die fünfköpfige familie ins
krankenhaus der vater und sein ältestes
kind haben das virus was den
gesundheitszustand der familie angeht so
ist der gesundheitszustand bei allen
familienmitgliedern stabil wir haben die
patienten deswegen trotzdem isoliert
weil wir es natürlich versuchen die
infektionsketten zu minimieren das neue
corona wir es gibt noch viele rätsel auf
die ärzte in oberbayern sind sich sicher
die anderen familienmitglieder sind auch
infiziert obwohl der test bei ihnen noch
nicht angeschlagen hat
das wäre ein neues phänomen bisher
gingen experten immer davon aus dass die
zeit zwischen ansteckung und
krankheitsausbruch bis zu 14 tage
beträgt das ist insofern bedeutsam weil
er mensch der noch keine symptome hat
jetzt von sich aus auch keine
vorkehrungen treffen kann jemand anders
nicht anzustecken weil er nicht spürt
dass erkrankt ist und das ist eine
gewisse gefahr dass die ausbreitung
einer solchen erkrankung und dadurch
natürlich befördert wird aber ob das
tatsächlich so ist dass es steht noch
nicht sicher fest
der vergleich zur saß epidemie vor 17
jahren insgesamt wurden damals 8000 96
infektionen offiziell registriert und
774 tote sterberate für saas 9,5 prozent
bei corona melden die behörden jetzt
mehr als 9800 infektion schon jetzt also
mehr als bei saas tendenz deutlich
steigend 213 tote sterberate bisher rund
zwei prozent wenn die offiziellen zahlen
aus china stimmen würde das bedeuten
corona ist deutlich ansteckender aber
wohl weniger gefährlich als saas in der
chinesischen millionenstadt wo hahn
wurde das virus zuerst aufgetreten war
und am stärksten wütete läuft jetzt die
evakuierung von ausländern auf
hochtouren auch die bundeswehr hat ein
flugzeug geschickt und 100 deutsche
sollen damit nach hause geholt werden
und müssen dann allerdings einiges auf
sich nehmen tobias häfner
es ist ein besonderer flug der sich zur
stunde chinas millionen metropole wo
annähert am mittag war der luftwaffen
airbus code schumacher in köln gestartet
um rund 100 deutsche zurück in richtung
heimat zu bringen wenn erleichtert das
wäre jetzt an diesem punkt sind und die
schwierige situation in der unsere
landsleute vor ort sind jetzt dadurch
beendet wird
auf dem hinflug hat das flugzeug 10.000
schutzanzüge an bord china nimmt diese
hilfe von außen inzwischen gerne an denn
das problem corona virus wird immer
gigantischer und das obwohl sich die
menschen von nahezu allen öffentlichen
orten fernhalten
der verweis der fischmarkt von johann
als symbol für das derzeit oft
unsichtbare milliarden volk niemand
verlässt mehr sein haus unser geschäft
ist völlig tot
ein paar kilometer weiter zusätzlich
eine klare botschaft der behörden bleibt
besser wo ihr seid nur wenigen
fußgängern wird es gestattet den
großraum wo hahn über eine jangtse
brücke zu verlassen
check-in ziel europa frankreich hat
einige seiner staatsbürger bereits vom
flughafen woran ausgeflogen mindestens
ein passagier wurde nach der landung
positiv getestet buß kolonne für die
anderen
sie gehen zwei wochen lang in
südfrankreich in ein ungenutztes hotel
quarantäne
mehr eine medizinisch ähnliche prozedur
morgen für die deutschen untersuchungen
frankfurt später transfer in eine
kaserne in rheinland-pfalz zwei wochen
beobachtung dann soll auch hier klar
sein ist ein crooner infizierter dabei
oder nicht unser nächstes thema ein
historischer tag ist das heute für
großbritannien und europa der brh exit
tag ist da
nach all den jahren voller verhandlungen
abstimmungen streit die briten verlassen
die union mit gemischten gefühlen so
heute in london zu erleben die einen
erleichtert bis triumphierend bei den
anderen den sogenannten remains vor
allem viel wehmut und frust
egal wie man zum brett steht eine ära
endet wir erklären zunächst was das
bedeutet dreieinhalb jahre nach der
ursprünglichen volksabstimmung und drei
premierminister später nämlich cameron
may und nun johnson ist es soweit
gucken wir uns an was der brh exit jetzt
konkret bedeutet insgesamt 66,2
millionen briten verlassen heute die
europäische union sie verliert etwa
jeden achten ihrer bürger und ihre
zweitgrößte volkswirtschaft die unter
dem strich mehr einzahlten nämlich
sieben milliarden euro
als sie herausbekommen und nicht nur die
insel auch wichtige seegebiete drumherum
werden der eu fehlen die halbe nordsee
gehört den briten ein problem für viele
fischer vom festland und noch vieles
mehr
muss jetzt geklärt werden bis ende des
jahres so lang wird das vereinigte
königreich erstmal noch wie ein eu land
behandelt der tag heute aus britischer
sicht yasin herrlein ein letztes mal
noch standen sie sich gegenüber brad
pitt befürworter und dragset gegner
bevor heute abend gefeiert wird auf dem
parliament square jenem platz vor dem
parlament in dem so viele praxis
schlachten geschlagen wurden
heute um 11 werde ich meinen flachmann
mit teurem brandy aufmachen und ihn ganz
austrinken wenn das referendum damals
fair und ordentlich ausgetragen worden
wäre
das akzeptiert aber so bin ich jetzt
einfach wahnsinnig wütend
die regierung hielt ihre
kabinettssitzung heute symbolträchtig
ins sambaland im norden englands ab
jener stadt die sich in der referendums
nacht als erste für den austritt
ausgesprochen hatte wofür die menschen
im referendum und in der letzten
parlamentswahl gestimmt haben wird nun
endlich war das größte geschenk das wir
berieten der welt gemacht haben ist die
parlamentarische demokratie und wir
stellen hiermit das vertrauen in sie
wieder her doch bloß nicht zu triumphal
auftreten so das motto der regierung die
europaabgeordneten der exit partei
fühlten sich daran offensichtlich nicht
gebunden als sie heute unter
dudelsackpfeifer das parlamentsgebäude
in straßburg verließen nicht überall ist
der widerstand gänzlich gebrochen
zum beispiel in schottland wo die
dortige erste ministerin ein
unabhängigkeitsreferendum und den
wiedereintritt in die eu plant eine neue
50 pence gedenkmünze propagiert frieden
wohlstand und freundschaft mit allen
nationen das land erstrahlt in weiß rot
blau
die briten feiern ihre freiheit am
praxistag oder zumindest ungefähr die
hälfte von ihnen live nach london ein
paar stunden ist es noch in der eu diana
guten abend und nun wie geht's jetzt
konkret weiter zwischen großbritannien
und europa ja erst mal passiert gar
nichts die übergangsphase beginnt und
mit ihr verhandlungen die man glaubt es
kaum womöglich noch viel komplizierter
werden als das was wir bisher gesehen
haben
47 jahre lang waren großbritannien und
die eu wirtschaftlich eng miteinander
verknüpft nun muss alles auseinander
gezogen werden die meisten experten
gehen davon aus dass das in elf monaten
gar nicht möglich ist boris johnson aber
besteht darauf ende 2020 muss schluss
sein mit übergang und was wird der
größte streitpunkt werden
ja egal ob es um fischerei industrie
oder forschung geht überall diesen
verhandlungen schwebt eine frage wie
viel von der heute angeblich errungenen
freiheit will großbritannien wirklich
nutzen brüssel nämlich besteht darauf
der zugang zum binnenmarkt hängt davon
ab wie stark großbritannien sich
weiterhin an europäische regeln hält in
sachen arbeitnehmerschutz umweltschutz
und steuerrecht boris johnson wird sich
also entscheiden müssen zwischen engen
beziehungen zum wichtigsten
handelspartner seines landes und der
großen freiheit die er den briten mit
dem dragset versprochen hat der blick
nach vorn diana zimmermann herzlichen
dank das hick-hack um den brics it läuft
seit jahren und vieles passiert vom
referendum bis zum austritt heute auf
heute.de haben wir alle etappen für sie
noch mal zusammen gestellt und damit auf
die andere seite des atlantik ist es
heute ein entscheidender tag in
washington und für das
amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen us
präsident donald trump das könnte
nämlich heute bereits zu ende gehen und
das wäre ja positiv für den präsidenten
im senat geht es zunächst um die frage
ob neue zeugen gehört werden die
demokraten wollen das aber die mehrheit
im senat haben die republikaner 53 sitze
die demokraten haben 47 und brauchen
damit mindestens vier republikanische
senatoren die mit ihnen stimmen um so
auf die mehrheit von 51 zu kommen
es ist die frage die am ende über das
ganze verfahren entscheidet aus
washington britta jäger in martinsburg
west virginia sind sie eher konservativ
in dem bundesstaat hat donald trump mehr
als zwei drittel der stimmen geholt wenn
die moderatoren hier im lokalradio über
das thema amtsenthebung reden halten die
hörer ab meistens haben die leute schon
eine feste meinung und verfolgen das
alles nicht so genau ich denke dass es
viele einfach nicht wirklich
interessiert im rund 100 kilometer
entfernten washington steht der showdown
kurz bevor abstimmung darüber ob es im
verfahren weitere zeugen geben soll wie
etwa zum sex sicherheitsberater john
gurdon die demokraten müssen dafür vier
republikanische senatoren auf ihre seite
ziehen
von den potenziellen abweichlern aber
wollen nur zwei sicher ja sagen zu
zeugen
ein letzter appell der demokraten wenn
meine republikanischen kollegen sich
weigern zeugen und weitere dokumente in
betracht zu ziehen dann ist das hier die
größte vertuschungsaktion seit watergate
in are wo am montag die demokratischen
vorwahlen beginnen stellt sich trump am
abend vor seine anhänger
seine botschaft ich bleibe im amt die
besten handelt die jetzt das stärkste
militär
ich habe mich um die veteranen gekümmert
sie können sich auf mich verlassen und
die wollen mich des amtes entheben das
wird nicht funktionieren
sollten die republikaner zeugenaussagen
verhindern wird der senat wohl auch sehr
bald über trumps amtsenthebung abstimmen
und ihn sehr wahrscheinlich freisprechen
und noch die einschätzung aus washington
ist dass heute der tag an dem trump
aufatmen kann eigentlich schon so hat
man es erwartet aber es gibt ganz
dramatische szenen offenbar hinter
verschlossenen türen weil er am plan
noch mal was geändert werden könnte
eigentlich wollte man in den nächsten
vier stunden debattieren zeugen oder
nicht und danach abstimmen und danach
dann auch tatsächlich die abstimmung
durchführen
also schwamm schuldig oder nicht
schuldig sprechen mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit eben unschuldig und
das wissen eigentlich alle jetzt geht es
darum wie man es würde voll zu ende
bringt und da gibt es ganz offenbar auch
in der republikanischen partei einige
senatoren die wollen nicht unbedingt
schwamb die möglichkeit geben dass er am
nächsten dienstag hier bei seiner rede
zur lage der nation vor dem kongress
dann eine siegesrunde dreht und sich lob
dafür dass er freigesprochen wurde
sondern man könnte diese abstimmung die
abschluss abstimmung doch noch einmal
verschieben
am ende geht es allen darum im wahlkampf
in den nächsten wochen und monaten eben
gut auszusehen und sagen zu können das
war ein guter prozesses war ein
würdevolles verfahren während die
demokraten natürlich auch versuchen
werden zu sagen wenn es keine zeugen gab
war es auch kein prozess also die letzte
entscheidung über donald trump wird dann
eben im november bei den wahlen gefällt
werden sagt elmar theveßen live aus
washington
herzlichen dank damit zurück nach
deutschland bis eine neue straße oder
bahnstrecke bei uns ordnungsgemäß
geplant und behördlich genehmigt es
können jahre vergehen auch sehr viele
jahre das soll sich ändern künftig will
der bundestag wichtige verkehrsprojekte
per gesetz genehmigen
das haben die abgeordneten heute
beschlossen gelten soll das zunächst für
14 bahnstrecken und wasserstraßen und es
soll einfacher werden marode brücken
straßen oder bahnstrecken neu zu bauen
umweltverbände sind empört der
rechtsstaat werde ausgehöhlt sagen sie
sie kennen keine angst haben keine
skrupel und gehorchen bedingungslos die
rede ist von autonomen waffensystemen
künftig sollen sie ihr ziel eigenständig
suchen und angreifen ohne menschliche
kontrolle der markt boomt auch deutsche
rüstungsfirmen arbeiten an der
entwicklung solcher waffen so genannte
killer roboter sagen die grünen seien
ethisch fragwürdig sie gehörten verboten
der bundestag war heute mehrheitlich
anderer meinung und günter sonnenwald
roboter protest heute morgen vor dem
bundestag eine aktion der kampagne zum
verbot von kilometern aktivisten
verteilen rote karten dann abgeordnete
vor der abstimmung für ein verbot
tödlicher autonome fassen
alles das was so leicht einen menschen
von einer tötung zu entscheidung
abhalten könnte haben
noch werden die meisten unbemannten
waffen wie zum beispiel kampfdrohnen von
menschen gesteuert doch in zukunft
könnten voll autonome waffen ohne
menschliche kontrolle über leben und tod
entscheiden
die usa russland china und israel
entwickeln solche waffensysteme auch
deutsche hersteller setzen immer mehr
auf autonomie
die grünen forderten heute ein verbot
von autonomer wachsen
aufgrund der hohen geschwindigkeit
dieser automatisierten abläufe können
konfliktsituationen unnötig eskalieren
wenn keine ausreichende menschliche
kontrolle existiert denn auch die
sogenannte künstliche intelligenz macht
fehler
union und spd haben den antrag der
grünen heute abgelehnt obwohl sie im
koalitionsvertrag eine ächtung von
autonomer waffen vereinbart haben eine
regulierung ausschließlich auf
nationaler oder europäischer ebene so
wie sie der antragsteller fördert greift
hier zu kurz da sie den zukünftigen zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt noch nicht absehbaren
sicherheitspolitischen herausforderungen
nicht gerecht wird
mit der heutigen entscheidung hält sich
die bundesregierung eine tür offen für
die eigene forschung und entwicklung
autonomer waffensysteme damit ist klar
deutschland wird sich auch bei den
gesprächen in genf erst einmal nicht für
eine ächtung von killah robotern stark
machen
in australien waren die buschbrände
einigermaßen unter kontrolle doch jetzt
bedroht ein neues riesiges feuer die
hauptstadt canberra
der brand in einem nationalpark rund 40
kilometer von kern brent fällt breitet
sich weiter aus die behörden riefen den
notstand für die region aus
besonders gefährlich ist es wegen der
wetterlage erwartet werden temperaturen
um die 40 grad und regen ist nicht in
sicht
kein aufatmen also und wir bleiben in
australien mit dem sport und rudi ja und
melbourne aus der traum für alexanders
wäre vom finale der australian open
in seinem ersten halbfinale bei einem
grand-slam-turnier unterliegt
deutschlands bester tennis-profi den
österreicher dominik team mit 6 zu 3 4 6
6 7 und 6 7
melbourne erlebt heute einen rein
deutschsprachiges halbfinale das
eigentlich keinen verlierer verdient gab
es zwölf gewinnt den ersten satz und im
zweiten auch diesen fast unglaublichen
ballwechsel
denn nur als ein beispiel gelten kann
für ein hochklassiges tennis match
doch dem österreicher gelingt der
satzausgleich und dem dritten durchgang
wehrte er zwei satzbälle des deutschen
ab bevor er sich dann den tie-break
sichern kann
ja ich habe meine chancen gehabt im
moment hat besser gespielt als ich
vielleicht mutiger es verdient im finale
spielt sein bestes tennis in seinem
leben finde ich jetzt und ich denke er
wird auch chancen haben sondern auch der
vierte satz findet wieder in den tie
break
und auch diesmal ist dominic thiem der
um wenige punkte bessere zweier
ausgezeichneter tennisspieler am sonntag
im finale wartet nun auf in der
weltranglisten erste novak djokovic
tolle ballwechsel der wechsel von
fußball nationalspieler emre can von
juventus turin zu borussia dortmund ist
perfekt der 26 jährige nationalspieler
2017 siege des confederations cup mit
deutschland wird zunächst ausgeliehen
und erhält ab sommer einen
vierjahresvertrag die ablösesumme soll
rund 23 millionen euro betragen und noch
der erfolg für vinzenz geiger zum
auftrag des seefeld triple der nordische
kombinierer hat beim dreitägigen
saisonhöhepunkt platz zwei belegt er war
heute wieder nicht zu schlagen johannes
rieger vinzenz geiger links der einzige
der das in dieser saison zweimal
geschafft hat fliegt in seefeld 100 1
meter weit lieber landet bei 105 einhalb
meter und geht mit komfortablem
vorsprung als erster in die fünf
kilometer langlauf loipe
der weltcupführende lässt sich den sieg
nicht nehmen vinzens geiger aber kann
den kampf um platz zwei trotz erkältung
für sich entscheiden
richtig glücklich dass es da also klappt
aber es war sehr sehr haben triple
favorit bleibt wohl der mann aus
norwegen und mehr wintersport live im
zdf morgens von 9 uhr 35 jahren kann ich
dir wärmstens empfehlen da meistens
empfehlen ist das stichwort haben sich
lange und viel schnee bei dir gesehen
jetzt bei uns das wetter frühling im
februar
und was das für das wochenende genau
heißt das sagte ihm gleich katja
horneffer
im heute-journal der kollege claus
kleber um 22 uhr morgen freut sich hier
barbara hahlweg auf sie ich sage danke
für ihr interesse und wünschen allen
einen angenehmen freitagabend
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren heute
regnete es vor allen dingen im norden
deutschlands von frankreich und den
niederlanden her setzte sich aber auch
mal die sonne durch und so bleibt ist
auch heute nacht hier am alpenrand klar
und deswegen sinken dort die
temperaturen bis minus 2 grad sonst ist
es aber meist bedeckt wird in
norddeutschland fällt auch regen das
wird wieder eine sehr milde nacht bei
tiefsttemperaturen von 11 bis 7 grad
und morgen vormittag beginnt es zu
schütten zunächst in rheinland pfalz in
hessen und in nordrhein westfalen
während es zwischen dem allgäu und im
bayerischen wald noch recht freundlich
ist der regen zieht im laufe des tages
weiter nach osten und bis zum abend
erreicht er dann auch berlin brandenburg
sachsen thüringen und bayern
während im westen dann schon wieder die
wolken auflockern das ganze bei einem
starken bis stürmischen wind und so wird
es sehr mild morgen liegen die
temperaturen zwischen 9 grad in
schleswig holstein und 16 grad an der
unteren donau
auch am sonntag gibt es noch viel regen
und eine reelle chance auf sonne haben
sie eigentlich nur an der nordseeküste
bei 7 bis 15 grad
die neue woche startet sogar noch wärmer
mit bis zu 18 grad und sehr stürmisch
danach kommt der temperatursturz schönen
abend noch